Speaker 1: This is super interesting.
One of the most interesting interviews I've
seen in a while.
Nigel Farage was a member of the British Parliament
under the UKIP party.
That's the UK Independence Party.
It's a right wing populist rhetoric type party
that has a lot of overlap with MAGA.
Trumpism.
As disturbing and hilarious as that is, Nigel
Farage for a while has been saying, I don't
think Trump should keep talking about how
2020 was rigged.
Whether it was or wasn't rigged, Trump shouldn't
keep talking about it.
It's not going to help Trump win in 2024.
Nigel Farage interviewed Trump and actually
said to him, I wouldn't keep talking about
that.
And Trump kind of gets defensive and says,
Well, listen, I'm talking about it because
you brought it up.
But then later says, But it was rigged.
Okay, let's dive into this interview.
Fascinating.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: My point to you is, if you're going
to win this next year in November 2024, you're
not going to win it.
Talking about what happened last time.
But you have to have you've got to set a positive
message 100%.
Speaker 6: You brought this up to me and then
bring it up and I show you something.
I said, look, it was real.
And I say that I'll always say that.
It doesn't mean that out of a one hour speech,
I'm going to devote half of it to this.
I might.
Speaker 1: Have, except he kind of does.
Speaker 6: 10 seconds to it.
I could.
The election was rigged.
It was a rigged election.
It was a very dishonest election.
Speaker 1: I don't know that Nigel Farage
is correct.
And what I mean by that is when you survey
MAGA voters, they overwhelmingly believe that
it was rigged.
When you survey Republican voters in general,
they also to a lesser degree than the hardcore
MAGA types.
But they also have fallen for this idea that
2020 was rigged.
So I don't have the answer empirically as
to whether in a general election, on balance,
the message that 2020 was rigged as part of
a 2024 election brings voters in or pushes
voters away.
It's not obvious to me one way or the other,
I think is the point that I'm trying to make.
Trump continuing with the election was rigged
stuff.
Even during this interview.
Speaker 6: The election was rigged and Rupert
Murdoch should have talked about it.
Speaker 4: But Rupert Murdoch doesn't believe
he can win a court case on that.
Speaker 6: But Rupert Murdoch's wrong.
And whoever settle this case for that much
money.
And I think it was an insult not only to Fox,
it was an insult to all the people that work
there.
It was an insult to everybody that knows what
happened during that election.
Number one, they didn't use the legislation.
Number two, if you just look into modern times,
just look over the last couple of months,
the FBI dealt with Twitter.
Take a lot Twitter files.
Speaker 1: Understand none of this.
It's not only that, none of this proves it
was rigged.
None of this even relates to the election
in a direct way.
Speaker 6: That was cheating.
You look at look at the 51 different.
I have no doubt.
I look at the 51 different intelligence agents,
so-called intelligence agents.
They all lied 100%.
They lied.
All of this stuff is cheating.
And then you look at truth to vote, where
hundreds of thousands of ballots were stuffed
in the ballot boxes.
Speaker 1: They were stuffed with.
Usually we do like a ham and gruyere, but
they might have stuffed them with something
different.
So Trump's legal advice remember his brilliant
legal advice from the guy who lost 60 something
court cases related to the 2020 election?
His legal advice to Fox News was prove that
Trump really won, and then by definition it
wouldn't have been defamation where that that
that ultimately Fox's lawyers did not go that
way and they agreed to pay 787 and a half
million dollars to dominion voting systems.
Other items from this interview that are certainly
interesting.
Trump insisting that he will end the Russian
incursion into Ukraine within 24 hours, maybe
in that wacky town hall that's scheduled for
next week.
Kaitlan Collins can ask exactly how would
he do that?
Speaker 3: I will end.
Speaker 6: That war in one day.
It'll take 24 hours.
I know Zelensky Well, I know Putin well.
I will get that ended in a period of you.
Speaker 4: Can break that deal.
Speaker 6: 100%.
It would be easy that it would be easy.
A lot of it has to do with the money.
A lot of it has to do with the military.
You know.
Speaker 1: Trump would wrap it up quickly.
He would go, listen, Ukraine goes to Putin.
It's now part of Russia.
Let's end this entire thing.
In all seriousness, I would love for Trump
to be pressed just once on exactly how he
would end that conflict.
In 24 hours, the topic of the coronation of
the new British king came up, and Trump says
he was extraordinarily surprised that Biden
would not be attending.
Speaker 4: That Mr. Biden's not coming.
What does that say about his relationship
with the UK?
We get the feeling here.
Yeah, he's very, very pro Ireland.
He completely ignores the fact that Biden
is in fact an English name.
He's got English relatives.
He doesn't seem to like us very much.
Speaker 6: I don't think he can do it physically,
actually.
I think that it's hard for him to do it physically,
I think.
Over here for him.
He's got a lot of things going and a lot of
strange things happen.
But I'm certainly he should be here as a representative
of our country.
I was surprised when I heard that he wasn't
coming.
You would think he would be here.
He'll be in Delaware, where he spends a lot
of time.
He spent a lot of time there during the election.
Speaker 4: In the bunker.
Speaker 6: So I don't know.
It's in his.
Speaker 1: Bunker.
So, listen, there's a long held tradition
that American presidents don't go to British
coronations.
Jill Biden is going and that's fine.
But there's actually nothing particularly
unusual about that.
But again, it's this is an alternate universe.
Sticking with the subject of royal elements,
topics related to the royal family.
Donald Trump said that Meghan Markle treated
the Queen very disrespectfully, which I mean,
guy, this this is.
Speaker 6: I think is going to be a great
day.
And I think that they will do a great job.
Yeah, and he loves the country, really.
I get to know him quite well and he loves
the country, really loves the country.
And he loved his mother.
And that's why I said that it was she was
treated so disrespectfully by Megan and just
no reason to do that.
I was actually surprised that Harry was invited,
to be honest.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Very, very surprising.
And of course, Trump's the guy who truly disrespected
the former queen.
He was late and kept her waiting.
And then he baselessly stepped in front of
her.
I mean, just everything is backwards.
Everything is the opposite of what this guy
says.
And then lastly, Nigel Farage asking Trump,
So are you going to win next year?
And Trump's response not exactly projecting
huge confidence.
Speaker 4: Final thought.
Are you going to win next year?
Speaker 6: I think we have a very good chance.
And the economy is not good.
I'll make it good.
Everyone knows.
You know.
Even Democrats, they say, well, we agree that
Putin would have never gotten it.
He would.
And I tell you, not going in.
Speaker 1: So going into a word salad that's
unrelated after saying, I think we've got
a shot.
Speaker 6: Putin would have never gone into
Ukraine.
President Xi of China would never even be
talking about Taiwan.
We had that conversation strongly.
I stopped North Korea from doing some really
bad things in my relationship.
All right.
Speaker 1: So he goes and talks about other
stuff.
Trump does something that is often seen.
I know that this is going to sound so pejorative,
but I'm not.
I'm being totally serious.
I'm not saying Trump is wildly mentally ill
or anything like that, like he might be, but
I'm just not saying it here.
There is an observation that is often done
when someone is evaluated psychiatrically
about whether they have this sort of like
tangential thinking.
And Trump has it to an incredible degree where
he's simply asked, Are you going to win next
year?
And he talks about his relationship with Kim
Jong un.
And it's really I mean, you call it a feature
or a bug of Trump's speech, but it is there
very strongly.
So famous last words.
I think we lose the we I think we have a good
chance at winning in 2024.
Bizarre interview and all coming around the
same time that Trump got some very bad legal
news.
Let's talk about that next